[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في حصاد هذه الليله معكم ال سي
ابي عاصي في الوقت الذي احدثكم فيه تقع
واحداث وتتفاعلوا اخرى البدايه من واشنطن
تحديدا مبنى الكونجرس حيث فشلا وابو
الامريكيون اليوم في انتخاب رئيس لهم بعد
تصويت خامس في سيناريو غير مسبوق منذ 100
عام
والى هذه الصوره من شارع الام تريزا وسط
بريشتين عاصمه كوسوفو حيث ترصد كاميرا
الجزيره الاوضاع بعد اعلان قوه حفظ السلام
التابعه لحلف شمال الاطلسي انها تعمل على
ازاله ما تبقى من حواجز للاقليه الصربيه
والى العاصمه الصوماليه مقديشو واعلان
مسؤول امنيه ان عدد ضحايا التفجيرين
اللذين وقع في مدينه محاس باقليم هيران
ارتفع الى 35 قتيلا كما اصيب 25 اخرين
وفي مواضيع الحصاد لهذه الليله
ما بعد اقتحام بن كزير باحات المسجد
الاقصى مجلس الامن يعقد جلسه خاصه لبحث
الانتهاكات في القدس وحكومه نتنياهو تكسف
جهودها لمنع انعقاد الجلسه واشنطن تؤكد
لفظها اي اجراءات احاديه تقود الوضع
التاريخي القائم للاماكن المقدسه في القدس
والمانيا تدعو حكومه نتنياهو لوقف
الاستفزازات المتعمده
في سيناريو غير مسبوق منذ 100 عام خلافات
بين الاغلبيه الجمهوريه تحول دون اختيار
رئيس جديد لمجلس النواب الامريكي اعتراضات
على المرشح الابرز كيفن مكارثي رغم حصوله
على تاييد ترامب وجو بيدن يصف المازق
بالمحرج ويقول ان ما سماها فوضى تصويت
الجمهوريين تؤثر سلبا على صوره الولايات
المتحده
في اشاره للغرب بان موسكو لم تتراجع بشان
اوكرانيا روسيا تنشر فرقاه بصواريخ فرط
صوتيه
واكياس تعلن بدا نقل منظومه بيتريوت
الامريكيه الى اراضيها وتحذر من ان روسيا
تخطط لاستدعاء مزيدا من القوات لشن هجوم
كبيرا لتغيير مسار الحرب
في لقائنا اليوم قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه ناقشنا الازمات الاقتصاديه
والنقديه وارتفاع معدلات التضخم في دول
العربيه عده ما تسبب في زياده معدلات
التضخم وغلاء الاسعار وتفشي الفقر
والبطاله والضعف مرتبات لاستطاع ارائكم
بشان هذا الموضوع كنا قد طرحنا عليكم
السؤال التالي برايكم ما السبب في تفاقم
الازمات الاقتصاديه في دول عربيه عده وقد
جاءت اجاباتكم على نحو التاريخ نحو 24%
قالوا انها السياسات الخاطئه بينما صوت
نحو احد 10% بالقول انها الابعاد الدوليه
في حين يعتقد نحو 65% ان السبب هو تفشل
الفساد
هذا سؤال سيبقى مطروحا على منشتنا الرقميه
ويمكنكم دخول صفحه التصويت عبر مسح رمز
كيو ار الظاهري على الشاشه لقاءنا على
المنصات الرقميه يتجدد يوميا ولا تتطرق
خلاله بقضايا مستجده ومتفاعله عربيا
ودونيه
وتتابعون في فقره المتابعه
العمله المصريه تهبط الى ادنى مستوياتها
على الاطلاق والدولار يتخطى مستوى 26
جنيها بعد الطرح شهادات ايداع بعوائده
قياسه
[موسيقى]
اذا مازال اقتحام وزير الامن القومي
الاسرائيلي ايتامار بن كثير باحاثي المسجد
الاقصى يثير ردود فعل دوليه تتراوح بين
الرفض وابداء القلق والتحذير من مغبه
المساسي بالوضع القائم للاماكن المقدسه
وفي احدث المواقف عبرت المانيا عن رفضها
مواصفاتها بخطوات احاديه
تعرض الوضع التاريخيه الراهن في الحرم
القصير الخطر ياتي ذلك عشيه جلسه في مجلس
الامن تبذل حكومه الجديده جهدا لعرقله
عقدها بحسب وسائل الاعلام اسرائيليه
لا مفاجات كبرى
في التنفيذ
تثبت هذه الحكومه الاقصى في قلب المواجهه
تدليس باحاته من قبل زعيم الصهيونيه
الدينيه
الذي اقتحامها وهو وزير هذه المره نبهها
قالت معارضه الاسرائيليه الى خطوره تبعاته
العربيه والدوليه لفعله وزير الامن القومي
في حكومه نتنياهو الجديده فما ذلك تتلاحق
في الجانب الفلسطيني تبرز مطالبه رئيس
المكتب السياسي لحركه حماس اسماعيل هنيه
في مذكره بعثها لقاده المنطقه بموقف واضح
وحاسم تجاه جهود الحكومه الاسرائيليه
الراميه الى شطب حقوق الشعب الفلسطيني
والسيطره على ارضه وتهويد مقدساته الاضرار
بالوضع القائم فيما يتعلق بالاماكن
المقدسه في القدس هو ما تعارضه بشده الامم
المتحده والولايات المتحده والاتحاد
الاوروبي وهنا ترفض المانيا
احاديه الجانب تعرض الوضع التاريخيه
الراهنه في الحرم القدسي للخطر
الحكومه الالمانيه ترفض الخطوات الاحاديه
الجانب التي تعرض الوضع التاريخي الراهنه
في الحرم القدسي للخطر وقد اوضحنا مرارا
وتكرارا ان زياره هي استفزاز لذلك نرفض
بوضوح هذا النهج ونتوقع ان تلتزم الحكومه
اسرائيليه جديده بمواصله الممارسات الجيده
حول الاماكن المقدسه في القدس ووقف المزيد
من الاستفزازات المتعمده والسماح لجميع
المؤمنين والمهتمين بالوصول الى هذه
المنطقه وفي نفس الوقت ضمان تنفيذ
احتفالات المسلمين والصلاه في المسجد
الاقصى وحوله بطريقه كريمه لا يجد بن جرير
من يدافع عن خطوته المجمع على طابعها
الاستفزازي لكن هل ستنعكس موجه الاستنكار
الدولي موقفا حازما في المنابر الدوليه
تدفع نحو ذلك مشاعل دبلوماسيه فلسطين
وعربيه ودوليه لعقد جلسه لمجلس الامن
ستناقش الجلسه كما يفترض التطورات في
القدس على خلفيه اقتحام وزير الامن القومي
الاسرائيلي للمسجد الاقصى وربما تنضم الى
قضيه بحسب مسؤول الفلسطيني اعتداءات
مستوطنين يهود على مقابر مسيحيين في القدس
لن تدخر تل ابيبوس عن لابطال هذا المسعى
يكشف موقعه ولا الاخباريه الاسرائيلي صحيح
حكومه بنيامين نتنياهو لاحماطي صدور اي
قرار او بيان باسم اعضاء المجلس
ويوضح الموقع ان هذه المساعي تضمنتها
برقيه سريه لوزاره الخارجيه الاسرائيليه
ارسلت الى حوالي 15 سفاره وممثليه
اسرائيليه حول العالم
تخشى الحكومه الجديده في اسرائيل فيما يرى
متابعون من صدور ما يندل بسياساتها في
الاقصى بعد اقل من اسبوع على تشكيلها ليس
فقط لان ذلك سيشكل انتصارا دبلوماسيا
وسياسيا للفلسطينيين وانما ايضا لانه قد
يعرض حكومه ثانيه ياخذ ذهنيه المتطرفه
لمزيد من الضغوط في الداخل والخارج
خوري الكاتب الصحفي المختص في الشؤون
الاسرائيليه ومعنى من واشنطن الدكتور
السابق للتعاونه
في البيت الابيض خلال اداره الرئيس الاسبق
باراك اوبا مرحبا بكما سيد جاكي خوري هذه
الجهود الاسرائيليه لعرقلته عقد جلسه
لمجلس الامن هل تحمل ابعاد ودلالات مختلفه
هذه المره في ضوء الادانات الواسعه لما
قام به بينكفير من اق من المسجد الاقصى
بالامس
مساء الخير يعني واضح ان هنالك تخبط
اسرائيلي اداء ما حدث وعدم وجود خطه
استراتيجيه واضحه بالنسبه للتعامل مع هذا
الملف عن الاعلى اذا كانت الخارجيه
الايطاليه والمؤسسه دبلوماسيه كانت على
درايه بالنسبه لموجه ردود الفعل وبهذا
الزخم وبهذا الغضب من بدء من واشنطن وصولا
الى العواصم العربيه بما في ذلك ابوظبي
وطبعا دوله الامارات العربيه التي اراد
وخططا نتنياهو لزيارتها ولكن ياتي تاتي
هذه الجلسه كما ذكرنا ذكرتم في تقريركم
يعني بعد ايام فقط من تصويت الجمعيه
العامه للامم المتحده والتوجه نحو المحكمه
الدوليه بالنسبه لواقع الاحتلال وبالتالي
واضح ان هنالك امور تراكميه وفي ظل الصور
التي شهدناها يعني بالامس واضح ان هنالك
محاوله للتاثير ولكن اعتقد ان هناك قناع
اسرائيليه بان هذه الجلسه ستتم ولكن طبعا
السعيه لا تكوني ادانا بالتالي الموقف
الوحيد الذي يمكن ان يتخذ في هذه الحاله
هو اقناع اداره الرئيس ايه بيدن بان لا
تتخذ يعني موقف قد يكون متجانس تماما مع
الموقف العربي والاسلامي تحديدا الموقف
الفلسطيني الاردني في هذه الحاله ولكن هي
ايضا سمعنا قبل يعني قليل موقف سفيره
الاسرائيلي في الامم المتحده الذي يعتبر
ان هذه الجلسه فارغه من ناحيه مضمونها ولا
تؤثر على شيء ولكن كما ذكرت يعني واضح اذا
كان هنالك اي محاوله من قبل حكومه نتانيه
خاصه قبل يعني الاعلان عنها رسميا
وتشكيلها ودخول الوزراء الى مكاتبهم في
الايام الاخيره انه اراد بعض الايام
ليتعامل مع يعني همم المجاوره والمحيطه
بما في ذلك الدول العربيه فواضح ان خطوه
بين غير عمليه سحبت البساط من تحت قدمي
السؤال الى اي مدى هذه الاجواء ستستمر
لفتره طويله ام سينجح مثلا نتنياهو من
خلال حكومته ان يمهد مثلا لامور عينيه
ولكن واضح ان هذه الحكومه لا تملك اي
امكانيه او اي مصداقيه حتى من دول عربيه
تعرف بانها صديقه ولديها اتفاقيات ان تذهب
بهذا الاتجاهات
هناك ادانه دوليه واسعه كما ذكرنا لما قام
به
الاقتحامه المسجد الاقصى وهناك دعوات
لعدم تغيير الوضع القائم في الاقصى كيف
سيترجم هذا عمليا غدا في جلسه مجلس الامن
باعتقادك
ممكن ان اتوقعه من الاجتماع في نيويورك هو
عباره عن
اذنه واسعه وعريضه من الاعضاء
والولايات المتحده على لارجع سوف تقوم
بمنع اي قرار من شانه ينتقد اسرائيل بشده
ولكن دعونا لا ننساها حقيقه ان هذا اختبار
اساسيا لاداره كيف سيستطيعون التعامل مع
هذا الاستفزاز من حكومه نتنياهو الجديده
في الماضي
الحكومه الامريكيه كانت محجمه في العاده
بان تنتقد اسرائيل بقوه او بشده بسبب
السياسات المحليه هنا ولكن هذا يعتبره
نوعا جديدا من الحكومات الاسرائيليه وواضح
انه خلال الساعات الاولى والايام الاولى
فقط من حكومه نتنياهو نرى بانهم مستعدون
للقيام بامور تعتبروا بصراحه امور لم تقوم
بها حكومات اسرائيليه السابقه ولذلك هذه
اللحظه
لكي يظهر ان كان قادرا ام لا على كبح جماح
نتنياه وحكومته
سيتتصرف ستتصرف اداره بيدا خصوصا اذا
تحذيرات من ان هكذا خطوات تتبعها خطوات
اخرى قد تؤدي الى المزيد من العنف وتشعل
همم فتيل الازمه اكثر واكثر
نعم هذا هو الامر المهم وهو ان اداره
سوف تقوم بالنظر الى استراتيجيات من شانها
ان
لا تشجع اداره نتنياهم من السير في مزيد
من الاستفزازات هناك الكثير من الامور
والقضايا الدبلوماسيه والثقل الدبلوماسيه
الامريكيه التي يمكن ان نستخدمه لنرسل
رساله واضحه للاسرائيليين بان هذا النوع
من السلوك غير مقبول وان خفض التصعيد يجب
ان يتم اذا بالنظر الى الخطوات بما فيها
استعادته سفيرنا الى واشنطن او ذاك النوع
من الاجرات المشابهه سوف يكون مهما ولكن
طوال الوقت عندما تعتبر هذه السلوكيات في
واشنطن هي مرتبطه به قضيه وقرار سياسيه
لذلك هل بعيد مستعد لدفع هذا الثمن
السياسي لان الجمهوريين حتى اعضاء في حزبه
على الارجح سوف يقفون ضد اجراءات كهذه قد
يتخذها بيضا سيد جاك خوري الدكتور بات
بروين يقول ان الجلسه ربما يسفر عنها اذا
نواسعه لمقامت لمقام به وزير الامن القومي
من اقتحام للاقصى ولكن
الولايات المتحده ستعرق اي قرار هذه
الادانه الواسعه ان صدرت كيف تعتقد
ستتعامل معها حكومه وكيف يمكن ان تنعكس
على الحكومه
يعني كما تعلمين دائما كل حكومات اسرائيل
المتعاقبه تتعامل مع قرات الامم المتحده
بانها قررت يعني معاديه ومبنيه على توجه
معادل اسرائيل يعني منذ زمن طويل وبالتالي
ستستمر الامم المتحده بوجهه نظر ايصاليه
بهذه السياسه وانا اذكرك واذكر المشاهدين
هنالك عشرات القرارات التي صدرت عن الامم
المتحده وايضا قاره صادره عن مجلس الامن
التي لم تنفذ حتى الان وبالتالي ان يصدر
قرار ادانا قد يكون يعني مهم البعد
الدبلوماسي بتوجيه رساله معينه لحكومه
نتنياهو خاصه هذه الحكومه التي تعتبر
الاكثر تطرفا في تاريخ دوله اسرائيل ونوع
من بطاقه صفراء اذا تحدثنا بلغه كره القدم
لنتنيها ولي حكومتها انه لا يستطيع ان
يتحرك بحريه ولكن يمكن ان نقول ان هذه
الادانه لن تكون كافيه اذا لم تاتي خطوات
عمليه على الارض في مرحله لاحقه نحن نركز
الى لانه نصلي على اقتحام بينج في المسجد
الاقصى المبارك ولكن نذكر الجميع بان ايضا
الاراضي الفلسطينيه تحديدا الضفه الغربيه
ليست بافضل حال وهنالك قررت عديده ستتخذ
خلال الفتره القريبه ترتبط بالاستيطار قد
ترتبط بضمه مساحات كبيره من الضفه قد
ترتبط ايضا بطرد عشرات العائلات
الفلسطينيه اذا لم تكن مئات العائلات هل
سيتحرك مجلس الامن هل سيتحرك المجتمع
الدولي هل سيتحرك العالم العربي والاسلامي
ام كل الامور عمليه ستتقلص ببعد الاقصى
رغم اهميته ورمزيته ونتحدث عن قضيه جوهريه
اساسيه في الفلسطيني وبالتالي الادانه
بالامس او غدا عفوا يعني ستكون مهمه ولكن
اعتقد ما سيكون بعد ذلك من خطوات عمليه هو
الاهم وكيف سيترجم هذا من بعد الميزان
ذكرت ان اداره بايدا امام اختبار حقيقي مع
هذه الحكومه الحكومه
من كيفيه تطور الاوضاع الاراضي المحتله
اعتقد ان القلق الاول هو انه بصراحه هذا
الامر يمكن ان يصبح
اغفالا في التركيز لما يجري الان فهو يريد
ان يركز على روسيا واوكرانيا والصين
وقضايا دوليه اخرى اذا يعتبر الا هاء له
وصرفا له ولنظره عما يجري في الشرق الاوسط
ولذلك هذا سوف يكون صداعا لبيض اذا فهو
بالتالي
سوف يبدل كل الجهود لمحاوله اقناعه نتنياه
بانه لا ينبغي عليه ان يصير اكثر واكثر في
محاوله خلقه ظروف سوف
وعايز
نشر العنف اكثر واكثر ويجبر الامريكان
بالتالي بان يحولوا اهتمامهم الدبلوماسيه
لحل هذه الازمه بدلا من الاسماك الاخرى
المشاهدون لعلهم يعلمون بانه اخر مره كان
هناك ازمه اساسيه في الاراضي الفلسطينيه
وايد اتخذ خلالها
[موسيقى]
بنفسه عنها وترك الامر للمسؤولين
الاسرائيليين ولكن السؤال الان هو هل سوف
يتخذ نفسه التفتيك مع ادارته
وهي الان همم في هذا الوضع ام لا شكرا لك
الدكتور
المدير السابق لتعاون والانخراط الدولي
لحالي الازمات في البيت الابيض في دلاله
الرئيس الاسبق باراك اوباما ضيفنا من
واشنطن وشكرا للسيد جاك يا خوري الكاتب
الصحفي المختص الشؤون الاسرائيليه ضيفنا
من الناصره
[موسيقى]
مجلس النواب الامريكي يفشل للمره الخامسه
في انتخاب رئيس جديد له بعد ان اخفقت
محاولات سد فجوه خلاف جمهوريا جمهوريه
ويواجه انصار الجمهوريين
ونجاحهم في تحقيق الاغلبيه في المجلس خلال
الانتخابات النصفيه الاخيره عقبه الاكتمال
في ظل الخلاف على شخص المرشح للمنصب كفن
مكارسي
تصفيقات حاره في البدايه وحمى انتكاسه في
نهايه التصويت مجلس النواب الامريكي في
حاله لم تحدث منذ قرن اكثر من جلسه تصويت
واكثر من محاوله فاشله للمرشح الجمهوري
كيفن مكارثي للظفر بمصب الرئيس رئيس مجلس
النواب هو ثالث اهم شخصيه في الولايات
المتحده بعد الرئيس ونائبه فوضى وانقسامات
الجمهوريين جعلت التصويت هذه المره امرا
عسيرا الحزب الفائز بالاغلبيه في انتخابات
التجديد النصفي الاخيره يعجز عن لم شمله
واصلاح شرخه يحتاج المرشح لمنصب رئيس مجلس
النواب الى 2008 صوتا وعدد مقاعد
الجمهوريين في المجلس الحالي
222 لماذا لا يقنع مكارثي عضو الكونجرس عن
ولايتك كاليفورنيا رفقه الجمهوريين
بالنسبه
ناحيه اليمين هي المتشدد في الحزب فهو
متهم بعدم الولاء بدرجه كافيه للرئيس
السابق دونالد ترامب ترامب نفسه اعرب عن
دعمه لمكارسي في منشور له على موقع
كتب ان الوقت قد حان كي يصوت جميع
الجمهوريين في مجلس النواب لصالح انتخابي
كيف المكرسي رئيسا للمجلس
تنازلات مكه الاخيره ووعده بفتح تحقيقات
ضد الرئيس جوبيدا وعائلته
ومكتبه تحقيقات الفيدرالي في حال فوزه لم
تشفع له لا تخصمه والمفارقه انه كل ما رد
خالي المطالبهم فقد اصوات اخرى من
المعتدلين داخل حزبه كان البيت الجمهوري
من بعد حقبه ترامب مكتوب عليه الازمات
الداخليه يمكن الانتخاب رئيس مجلس النواب
ان يستدعي اكثر من جوله اختراعه وان
يستغرق ساعات او اسابيع في عام
1923 اختير رئيس المجلس بعد عده جولات
اقتراع وفي عام
1856 تحقق انتخاب الرئيس بعد شهرين و 133
جوله اختراع صوت الرئيس بيضا لم يضم طويلا
وادلب تصريحات منتقده لما يجري قال ان
فوضى تصويت الجمهوريين على رئيس مجلس
النواب لا تعكس صوره جيده للولايات
المتحده وهي محرجه مؤكدا بان التصويت على
رئيس مجلس النواب ليس مشكلته عدم التصويتي
قد يكون نعمه الله في حال الشلل التشريعي
قد يلقي بالله ما على الجمهوريين
المسؤولين عن التعقيل طبعا كله امل في قلب
الامور لمصلحه ادارته
بعد دعوات للخلوه والتكاتف وجمع الصفوف
لتجاوز الهزيمه الكارثيه لمكرتي في عده
جولات التصويت كيف سيتجاوز الجمهوريون
التشرزمهم اختيار خليفه نانسي بيلوسي في
مجلس النواب الامريكي هو الاصعب منذ 100
عام
السياسي في مجله نيوز
باعتقادك التي يريد الرافدين لانتخاب كفن
مكارثي اصالها من خلال عرقله انتخابه وهم
اساسا غير قادرين على ايصال مدين
هذا موضوع في غايه التعقيد من حيث ما يجري
وراء الكواليس
قدر اهميه ما حصل في العمل الذين يعرضون
كارثه يقولون بين العوده الى النظام
الاعتيادي الموجود في النظام التشريعي ولا
يريدون
كبيره
حول تحديث
ولكن خلف الكواليس الكثير من هذا المشكله
لا تت
باستهجانا الخلافات الشخصيه ضد السيد
مكارثي من قبل 20 او اكثر من الاعضاء
الذين يسوطون للشخص اخر يكون رئيس المجلس
كان هناك اعتقاد على نطاق واسع بيتر ان من
يقف وراء عرقله التصويت هي مجموعه مقربه
من الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب
يدعو هؤلاء لتصويت لما كارثه ومع ذلك لم
يصوتوا ما تفسير ذلك
مره اخرى
من اهميه الموضوع
تراجع عن موافقته والان هو يشجع الناس على
التصويت لما كان في الذي يحتاج الى ثمانيه
عشر من الاصوات العشرين المتوجهه لغيره
لكي يصبح الرئيس الجديد هم يتجاهلون ترامب
الذي يدعوهم اولا الى وهذا يعني ان الدعم
السياسي لترامب اولا
يعنيا بان هذا ليس همم عمل بل هذا الشيء
هذا الشيء شخصي لديهم استياء الشخصي من
مكان فيه ولديهم عدم ثقه شخصيه بمكه
كما يراه بعض رجاء بعض الجمهوريين ترامب
انه غير قادر على ان يتولى مهام رئاسه
المجلس بكرامه
وهذا و نزاهه وهذا هذه المشكله ليست لا
يكون حلها سهلا ورغم لقد لا تحل اطلاقا عن
طريقه التنازلات والمفاوضات
ولكن الان اي تداعيات على الحزب الجمهوري
وسورته في ضوء هذه الازمه خصوصا واننا
يعني وانا الحزب الجمهوريه يدخل الى مجلس
النواب به نتائج الى حد ما وصفت ضعيفه
بالمقارنه مع مكانها متوقعه
عايزين
ان هذه بس كابوس في العلاقات العامه
بالنسبه للجمهوريه ورغم ان بعض الرسائل
هنا الذين منهضونا مكارثي
صحيحه تماما مثل العوده الى النظام العادي
وفرصه وتقديمه اقتراحات وتعديلات اثناء
التشريع القوانين وهذا كله مباراه داخليه
الجمهوريون يبدو انهم قدموا
ويعوزهم التنظيم
وشعرنا بمشاكل كثيره كما هو حال المعارضه
كما تتمنى او تدعي المعارضه
الديمقراطيه لهم اي ان الحزبه الجمهوري لم
ل لم نعمه متماسكان ولا يبدو انه مستعد ان
يصير قدم الى الامام
رئيس التحرير في صحيفه واش تايمز سيد همم
جيد اهلا وسهلا بك ما الرساله التي يريد
الرافدون في الحزب الجمهوري
لانتخابي كفن مكارسي اصاله وهم غير قادرين
على ايصال مرشح اخر بمفردهم ماذا يفعلون
الرساله
المناسب لهذا المصري حقيقه انه ترامب
لمحاوله اقناع للناس معهم ويتعاون معهم
ههه
ايضا انتقل الى مكتب رئيس المجلس حتى قبل
انتخابه في مصر وهذا يعني ان لديه نوع
الغروب بنفسه
لدى من
يمتنع عن التصويت له يمنع ايصاله الى
رئاسه مجلس النواب كيف يمكن انتخاب رئيس
لمجلس النواب الامريكي في ضوء ما يحصل
دايم
221 بديلا
انقطع الصوت من المصدر
ما رايه سيد بيت الروف يعني لا يبدو ان
هناك تراجع عن هذه المعارضه
التنازلات التي قدمها ما التوجه باعتقادك
المحتمله لهذه الازمه
اه دائما
يجتمع بالناس المجموعه
كثيرا بيد حزب المعارضه همم
في اي لحظه
عن طريق التصويت
قبيحه لتخلى عن رئاسه شكرا
[موسيقى]
قالت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه انها اجرى
التجربه لصاروخي سرقن فرط الصوتي اضافه
الوزاره ان الصاروخ الذي اطلق من فرقاطه
الادمره في بحر البرنس اصاب هدفه في البحر
المتوسط في اثناء كشف وزير الخارجيه
الاوكراني عن بدء نقل انظمه الامريكيه الى
اوكرانيا
رسائل تصعيد تتبادلها ميدانيا البدايه من
موسكو التي ترفع من قدراتها الصاروخيه
كثير كون هو الصاروخ الاحدث الذي ادخلته
روسيا في الخدمه
نفذت وزاره الدفاع تجربه للصاروخ الذي
اصاب هدفه في البحر المتوسط بدقه عاليه
الكيلو متر تقريبا
وبحسب وزير الدفاع
التغلب على جميع انظمه الدفاع الصاروخيه
والجوي الحديثه والمستقبليه
وصف الاسلحه الحديثه التي دخلت الخدمه
بانها لا مثيل لها في العالم
تمتلك مثل منظومه الصواريخ السريعه هذه
والاسلحه الحديثه الاخرى من الجيل الحديث
انا متاكد ان مثل هذه الاسلحه القويه
ستحمر روسيا بشكل وثيق من التهديدات
الخارجيه المحتمله
وفيما بدا ردا غير مباشره قال رئيس
الاستخبارات الاوكرانيه كاريل بودانوف ان
بلاده تخطط لشن هجوم كبير في الربيع
المقبل على مواقع تمركز القوات الروسيه
اما وزير الخارجيه
الاوكرانيبا فكشف عن بدء نقل انظمه
بيتريوت الامريكيه الى اوكرانيا حيث سيتم
نشرها في اقرب وقت
[تصفيق]
الامريكيه لقد بدا العمل على نقل هذه
المنظمات
في اقرب وقت ممكن
يستمر القتال ميدانيا واعرفه يدور في ضخمه
حيث قالت القوات الاوكرانيه انها صدت
هجوما روسيا وتمكنت من استعادته بعض
المواقع التي فقدتها اما في بيوت الطول في
مقاطعه
فاستهدفت القوات الاوكرانيه ما قالت انه
مركز القياده العسكريه الروسيه في منطقه
خسائر في صفوف القوات الروسيه
ينضم الينا من موسكو اندريا فرولوف الخبير
العسكري والاستراتيجي ومعنى من عاصمه
ايرلندا الشماليه بلفاست العقيد فيلب
انجرام الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي
والضابط السابق بالمخابرات البريطانيه
مرحبا بكما عقيد فيلب انجرم كيف تقرا
الدول الغربيه الداعمه لاوكرانيا هذه
الخطوه الروسيه المتمثله باطلاقي الفرقاطه
عام 2018
الاطلسي الى المحيط الهندي الى البحر
المتوسط اطلاق صاروخ منها اليوم من بحر
برنس باتجاه البحر المتوسط كل ذلك همم ما
وقعه لدى الدول الداعمه لاكرانيا
يعتبر رساله فقط
في كل مناطق اهتمامهم وطرقم التجاريه
السفن في المياه الوطنيه
الحقيقه ضد الدول التي تدعم اوكرانيا لان
هذه الصواريخ يمكن
القدره على التعامل مع الغواصات الحقيقيه
هل توافق على هذا التحليل
نعم نعم نعم
روسيه واحده ولا نعرف كم صاروخان يمكن ان
تحمل هذه السفينه
والثانيه له ليس هناك الربط مباشر بين
الدعم اوكرانيا وهذه الرحله لهذه السفينه
الروسيه
جدا في الغرب هو الاطلاق هذه الصواريخ
السنوات الماضيه شكلها تهديدا او رساله
للغرب
الاحتفال باطلاق هذه الفرقات اليوم الرئيس
الروسي تحدث عن الاسلحه التي تحملها تحمي
روسيا من التهديدات الا توجد اي دلالات
لهذا الكلام في هذا التوقيت
ناقصه
جزء من القدرات الاستراتيجيه
الروسيه مثل القاصفات والصواريخ
الاستراتيجيه التي تكون على الاراضي
وصواريخ عبر القارات هذه السفينه واحده
[موسيقى]
ويصير الكبيره جدا بحيث يتصور كما لا يمكن
التصور
اوكرانيا عن دخول همم البيتريوت همم حيز
يعني الى الى المعركه همم كيف سينعكس ذلك
باعتقادك على مسار المسار المسار المعارك
في الميدان
ايه اللي فاكر ستؤثر بطريقتين مثل ما
فهمته هناك منظومه صواريخ واحده
لحمايه الانظمه الدفاع الجوي
تستهدف اهداف عاليه جدا متوسطه
والمسيرات الانتحاريه الايرانيه
المشاهد قوه جويه الروسيه تدخل الى مناطق
او الفضاءات اللي تسيطر عليها اوكرانيا
خوفا من اسقاطها
ستتعامل روسيا مع دخول منظومه البيتريوت
الى الميدان
ومتى توقعات بشان انعكاسها على الهجمات
الروسيه
اولا لانهم شاهد
الحوثيين في اليمن ان الحوثيين دمروا
التحتيه السعوديه في الصوامع باستخدام
مسيرات وصواريخ بدائيه وبالتالي تتعلق
بالمنظومه الروسيه
لن تغير
تؤثر التوازن لصالح اوكرانيا اضافه لان
الولايات المتحده ستبعث فقط منظومه واحده
وبالتالي لا يمكن هذه المنظومه واحده ان
تحمي كل ثانيه وبالتالي اعتقد قوه الجويه
الروسيه والمسيرات
والطائرات الروسيه الاخرى
غير شيء
على طيران الروس
يعرف ما هي قدرات
وهنا التحدث عن طبقات طبقات
كثير من السيارات
الاعلان الروسي بشان الفرقه الادمير
جروشكوف وجولتها عبر ثلاثه بحار واطلاق
صواريخ السيركون فوق الصوتيه من على متنها
بدات رسائل روسيه في مرحله حرجه وحساسه
يعيشها العالم بعد الحرب الروسيه على
اوكرانيا وفي ظل التوتر القائم بين موسكو
ودول الغربيه على راسها الولايات المتحده
نتعرف اكثر على الفرقات وخصائصها في هذا
العرض
ه الروسيه
بنيت على اساس ما يعرف بمشروع رقم 22 350
والصمت لاداء ادوار متعدده قادره على
تنفيذ ضربات طويله المدى لتدمير السفن
الحربيه والغواصات والقافله البحريه
ومجموعات الانزال البحري سميت السفينه
الاولى
للاتحاد السوفيتي تم البدء ببنائها في
فبراير 2006 وتم تشغيله نسخه الاولى منها
في يوليو 2018
235 مترا وعرضها 16 مترا وتضم طاقما يصل
الى نحو 200 وعشره اشخاص تميز الفرقاطه
كرسنتها من الاسلحه المدمره
اطلاق عمودي مجازا لحمله 16 صاروخ مضادا
للسفن يبلغ نحو 300 كلم
وتحمل خلايا الاطلاق الصواريخ المدى من
نوع كالبر بمدن يرابح بين مئه و201500 كلم
كما انها مزوده باثنتين وثلاثين خليه
اطلاق عمودي مجاهزه لحمل 32 صاروخ سطح جو
للدفاع الجوي وتتنوع بين النسخه البحريه
لمنظومه اس 300 واس 400 اعلن وزير الدفاع
الروسي سيرجيو اطلاقا صواريخ سيركون فوق
الصوتيه خلال مناوره اثناء مهمه فرقه
الاميره في المحيطين الاطلسي والهندي
والبحر المتوسط
وصواريخ سيلكون تزيد سرعتها على 10,000
كلم في الساعه ويصير مداها الى الف كيلو
متر ويمكن اطلاقها من الجو والبر والبحر
من السفن والغواصات كما يمكن تزويدها
برؤوس حربيه مختلفه بما فيها النوويه حددت
البحريه الروسيه احتياجها الى عدد يرابح
بين 20 و30 فرقاطه من الادمره
وفي 2020 تمت الاشاره انه سيتم تخصيص ثلاث
سفن للاصول الشمالي وثلاثه لاسطول المحيط
الهادئ واثنتين لاسطول البحر الاسود
[موسيقى]
في تراجع السعر صرف جنيه المصري مقابل
الدولار فقبل ساعه اظهرت بيانات تراجع
الجنيه المصري الى اكثر من 26% مقابل
الدولار وهو التهاوي الاكبر للجنيه مقابل
الدولار التهاوي جاء مباشره بعد طرح بنك
مصر والبنك الاهلي المملوكين للدوله شهاده
ادخار بعائد خمسه 25% سنويا لاجل عام
الجنيه المصري تعرض لتراجعات قياسيه ففي
مارس اذار الماضي خفض البنك المركزي قيمه
الجنيه بنسبه 15% الي يرتفع الدولار الى
من 15 الى 19 جنيها وفي نهايه اكتوبر سمح
البنك المركزي بانخفاض بنسبه تصل الى اكثر
من 14% بالتوازي مع الاتفاقي مع صندوق
النقد على قرض جديد
دافعه الدولار الى
23 جنيها الجنيه المصري اختتم عام 2022
ضمن قائمه اسوا عشر عملات في العالم بعد
ان فقد ال 60% من قيمته امام الدولار ما
تتعرض له العمله المصريه من هزات متتاليه
يعكس جانبا من الازمه النقديه الارقام
والتفاصيل تقربنا من مشهد الازمه
فالاحتياطي النقدي لدى مصر لا يتجاوز نحو
33 مليار ونصف مليار دولار من بينها ودائع
في دول عده بالاضافه الى حصيله بيع اصول
ديون مصر الخارجيه تضاعفت اكثر من ثلاث
مرات في السنوات العاشره الاخيره لتصل الى
157 مليار دولار في بلد يستورد اغلبيه
احتياجاته من الخارج وشاهدت فيه اسعار
الفائده ارتفاعا بمقدار ثمانيه في المئه
في العام الماضي كانت تاثير فوريا اذ بلغت
نسبه التضخم نحو 19 في المئه الارقام
الرسميه
واذا كانت الاسعار ترتفع فاحد الاسباب هو
عجز المستوردين عن الحصول على الدولارات
اللازمه من المصارف وتفيد مصادر حكوميه ان
في الجمارك حاليا بضائع بقيمه نحو سبعه
مليارات دولار وبسبب ازمه النقد الاجنبي
قيدت معظم البنوك السحب بالدولار خارج مصر
كما رفعت عموله استخدام البطاقات
الائتمانيه في عمليات الشراء في الخارج
لثلاثه من ثلاثه الى 10 في المئه للمزيد
ينضم الينا من امتاريو كندا مصطفى يوسف
الباحث في الاقتصاد السياسي سيد مصطفى
يوسف مرحبا بك ماذا يعني ان يفقد الجنيه
المصري اكثر من 60 في المئه من قيمته
ويصبح ضمن اسوء 10 عملات في العالم
معنى ذلك ان يعني تكلفه المعيشه على
اغلبيه المصريين اكثر من نصف المصريين
سيجدون الصعوبه الشديده جدا في الحصول على
يعني الغذاء
ويعني ولم يستطيعون العيش بشكل كريم لان
مصر تستورد اكثر من 70% مما ياكله
المصريون حتى الصادرات المصريه يدخل في
اكثر من نصفها مكون اجنبي مستورد فستفقد
مصر قدرتها التنافسيه في التصدير
تهاوي العمله بهذا الشكل امر خطير ومخيف
وينذر هبوط اكثر من يعني همم 60% كان في
2019 كما قالت التقرير البنك الدولي انهم
من المصريين فقراء او معرضون الفقه
انها انهيار الكبير للعمله في 2022 ثم
الانخفاض الاخضر الذي حدث اليوم ومتوقع
لان السوق الموازي الدولار يتجاوز فيها 30
جنيه متوقع ان يزداد انخفاض مستوى معيشه
المصريين وانعدام قدره مصر على التصدير
بكل اسف في موضوع في الموضوع الاقتصاديه
الداخليه نحن نتحدث عن ارتفاع فوائد ازمه
في النقد في النقد الاجنبي تقييد السحور
السحب من المصارف هذا كله يبدو شبيها الى
حد بعيد بالسناريو اللبناني ما الذي يحصل
يعني حقيقه يعني السيناريو المصري اكثر
قتاما من اللبناني لان يعني مصر يعني كانت
قبل بدء الجمهوريه الجديده في يوليو 2013
سعر صرف الجنيه امام الدولار 6 جنيه 35
قرش الان في السوق الموازيه اكثر من 30
جنيه
يعني انخفضت بخمس امثال قيمتها اااه نحن
امام يعني ظاهره في المنطقه
عدم الاهتمام باي خطط فنيه عدم وجود همم
يعني همم انفاق كافي على الرعايه الصحيه
او على التعليم همم وخطه التنميه او على
دعم الصادرات او على دعم الصنارات الصغيره
والمتوسطه التي تساهم في رفع مستوى الحياه
المصريين وعلى الجانب المقابل نجد ان
الحكومه يعني المؤسسه العسكريه ت- تستحوذ
على اكثر من 75% من الاغتصاب المصري
بامر الاول الامر للاخر الانفاق على
مشروعات بطبعها اجهاري يعني ماذا يفيد
المصريين ان يكون لديهم اكبر كاتدرائيه في
افريقيا واكبر جامع في افريقيا واكبر ساري
علم او ماذا يفيد المصريين ان يكون لديهم
قصر رئاسيه 10 انفال مساحه البيت الابيض
يعني نحن امام ظاهره يعني دوله يعني فقيره
جدا فقير يعاني الامرين كي ياكل او يتعلم
او يحصل على رعايه طبيه كريمه ونظام قوي
ومسيطر يعني يعني يكفي ان نعلم في كل هذه
الازمه حينما انخفض الجنيه 60% من قيمته
في نفس السنه يعني في نفس الاشهر تم
الاعلان عن وجود الطائره رئاسيه فخمه يعني
ملكه السماء ب 487 مليون دولار تكلفه
الطيران في الساعه الواحد اكثر من 13,000
دولار فكيف يتاثر هذه الصوره يعني حقيقه
لا تتصل تجربه
الان دعا نتحدث عن الحلول ما هي الحلول
التي تلجا اليها السلطات المصريه لمحاوله
انقاذ ما يمكن انقاذه وما الذي يجدر فعله
لا ينبغي ان يكون هناك راسان لدوله
المؤثره العسكريه والدوله المصريه ينبغي
الا يتم بيعه الاصول كما تتم الان دون
شفافيه ينبغي ان تباع هذه الاصول المصريين
في الداخل او المصريين في الخارج لكي يتم
الحصول على عمله صعبه ويتم الافراج عن
الواردات ينبغي ان يتم مكافحه الفساد بين
المشروبات والاقتصاديه التي تم انشاءها في
السنوات الاخيره مثل العالمين الجديده
والعاصمه الجديده والقصور وما الى ذلك حتى
يعني يعني يتم الانفاق على ما ينبغي ان
تنفق عليه الدوله الدوله ليست دوله غنيه
والشعب الشعب الفقير ينبغي ايضا ان يتم
وجود شفافيه كامله همم وتداول المعلومات
حين يتم تقييم اي اصل من الاصول كي يتم
بيعه همم ينبغي ايضا ان تعاد النظر في
اتفاقيات البيئيه وخطوط الترسيم لح الغاز
لان هناك يعني اقوال كثيره جدا في اوراق
بحثيه ان هناك حقول غزم السريه تم يعني
التنازل عنها لليونان وقبرص اسرائيل
لنقيمت اكثر من 200 مليار دولار يعني كل
هذه الامور ستساهم اولا في حل الازمه انيه
ثم تشجيع الاستثمار الاجنبي الاستثمار
الاجنبي لن ياتي في دوله تشيطر فيها
المؤثره العسكريه على 75% من اقتصاد
المستفيدين الاجانب سيؤتون حينما تكون
هناك شفافيه هناك نوع من انواع السيارات
القانون وكذلك خطط تنميه تكفل للمصريين ان
تكون لديهم قوه الشرائيه كافيه حتى يتم
انعاش السوق المحلي زياده الصادرات
المصريه والحد من الوارده
في الاقتصاد السياسي
[موسيقى]
بينما ننهي الحصاد هذه الليله نصلي الضوء
مجددا على فيروس الاخبار طيبه فقد قال
مسؤولون من منظمه الصحه العالميه اليوم ان
البيانات الوارده من الصين تظهر انه لم
يتم العثور على متحول جديد
نطاق المرض وكيفيه منعه من الانتشار يتعين
علينا جميعا الالتزام باجراءات الوقايه
والحمايه فهي خير من العلاج بطبيعه الحال
دمتم بخير شكرا لكم على حسن المتابعه
[موسيقى]